(dramatic music)
Can I help -
Stop. That's enough, okay?
Maybe you should - you should...
(somber music)
♪ Like the sweet morning dew ♪
♪ I took one look at you ♪
♪ And it was plain to see ♪
♪ You were my destiny ♪
♪ With my arms open wide
I threw away my pride ♪
♪ I'll sacrifice for you,
dedicate my life to you ♪
♪ I will go where you lead,
always there in time of need ♪
♪ And when I lose my will, ♪
♪ You'll be there to push me up the hill ♪
♪ There's no, no looking back for us ♪
♪ We got love, sure enough that's enough ♪
♪ You're all, all that I need ♪
♪ to get by ♪
♪ 'Cause we, we got the right foundation ♪
♪ And with love and determination ♪
♪ You're all, all that
I wanna strive for ♪
♪ Do a little more ♪
♪ You're all, all the joys under
the sun wrapped into one, ♪
♪ You're all, all that I need ♪
(ears ringing)
♪ All that I need ♪
♪ to get by ♪